Writer's block is a complete myth. If
you have writer's block and you're
staring at a blank page, it's because
you either don't care about the thing
that you are writing for or you do not
know enough about the thing that you are
writing for. And it's usually the first
one. Like if somebody called me and
said, "Hey Allan, I want you to write a
sales letter for my roofing company." I
would have writers block because one, I
don't give two rips about roofs. And
two, I don't know two rips about roofs.
And so I'd have to spend a lot of time
researching inside of a market that I
don't care about. And so the information
just does not resonate with me. I don't
care at all. And so the best way to
combat writer's block is to write for
yourself. Write for the thing that you
want to write about and build a
newsletter or a paid community around
it. Like for me, I like watches and golf
and stuff like that. Let's say I wanted
to write about golf. Well, I could go
write online about golf. I'm naturally
reading about golf. I can study golf.
And so I have this natural desire to
want to learn about it. So the market
research is easy, the writing is easy,
the learning is easy, which makes
everything else in the business easy.
Then you can build an online audience,
move them to an email, and then sell
them a paid newsletter or a paid
community for recurring revenue. All
built around something you love. So that
way when the roofing client calls you,
you could tell them, "I don't want to
write for your roofs because I don't
care about roofs and I don't need to
write for your roofs." So, the best way
to eliminate writers's block is